From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，欢迎收听《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
My name is Marlene. I'm a senior at Lakeview High School, and I've had a crush on this one guy for four years. At first, it was like, OK, he's cute. Yeah, let me get to know him. And then, after a while, it's, OK, I really know you, and you really know me. So do you like me? Like, giving out hints but not really saying anything. And then it goes into-- when you walk down the hall, trying to touch hands to see if he'll actually grab your hand and stuff like that.
我叫玛琳。我是湖景高中的大四学生，四年来我一直暗恋着一个男生。起初，我觉得，好吧，他挺可爱的。嗯，让我去了解他一下。后来，过了段时间，我又想，好了，我真的了解你了，你也真的了解我了。那你喜欢我吗？就像那种不断发出暗示，却什么都不明说。再后来就变成了——当你走在走廊里，试着去触碰他的手，看看他会不会真的抓住你的手，诸如此类的事情。
There's times where it's like that, and you know he doesn't like you. But then, then, there's times like this one time, I sneezed. And he looked at me, he goes, "You have a really cute sneeze." It's like, Oh my god. What are you doing to me? Because it's just totally mixed signals.
有时候会是那样，你知道他不一定喜欢你。但也有的时候，像有一次，我打了个喷嚏。他看着我说：“你的喷嚏打得真可爱。”我就想，天哪。你到底对我做了什么？因为这完全是混乱的信号。
With a crush, everything is more intense. Everything your crushee says and does is freighted with such meaning.
有了暗恋对象，一切都变得更加强烈了。你暗恋对象所说和所做的一切，都承载着极其深远的意义。
I was all day on that sneeze comment. I must've told every single one of my friends. And I was like, man, it's this stupid little "you have a cute sneeze" thing. And I was like, man, OK, get over it. Get over it. No big deal. But it was the highlight of my day, man.
那一整天我都在想那个关于喷嚏的评论。我肯定告诉了我所有的朋友。当时我就想，天哪，这只是个关于“你打喷嚏很可爱”的愚蠢小事。我对自己说，行了，忘掉它吧。忘掉它。没什么大不了的。但那确实是我那天最开心的时刻。
Having a crush, anybody knows, means being utterly, miserably, dejected and completely filled with hope at the same time. But after four years of an on-again, off-again crush on this guy, just last week, Marlene started seeing somebody else. And she says that compared with dating, a crush is better better in certain ways.
任何人都会明白，暗恋意味着同时处于一种既彻底绝望、又充满希望的矛盾状态。但在断断续续暗恋这个男生四年后，就在上周，玛琳开始和别人约会了。她说，与约会相比，暗恋在某些方面其实更好。
The whole you don't know who he is, and you don't know if he likes you, and that trying to bump into him every day and stuff. But when you start dating somebody, it's just a normal thing. It's not something spontaneous. If you have a crush, you do anything just to be in his way, and it's just all this spontaneous, exciting thing. You have a boyfriend, it's just like, OK, yeah, OK. It's 3 o'clock. I see you now.
那种你不知道他是谁，不知道他是否喜欢你，每天试图和他偶遇之类的感觉。但当你开始和某人正式约会时，这一切就变得很平常了。不再那么自发且充满惊喜。如果你在暗恋，你会做任何事来制造偶遇，那一切都是那么自发且令人兴奋。如果你有了男朋友，那就只是，好吧，嗯，好的。现在3点了，我见到你了。
Well, today on our program, for Valentine's Day, stories about love in its earliest stage. Crushes. What's terrible about them, what's great about them, and how they can overshadow real love for some people.
好了，在今天的情人节节目中，我们要讲关于爱情最初阶段的故事。暗恋。它们的可怕之处，它们的伟大之处，以及它们如何让某些人的真实爱情黯然失色。
Act One of our program, Kiss. Tobias Wolff has the story of a crush that lasted a lifetime.
节目的第一幕，“吻”。托拜厄斯·沃尔夫带来了关于一段持续了一生的暗恋故事。
Act Two, How a Bill Becomes-- A President, in which a press secretary for a major presidential campaign explains the dynamics of crushes that are not about love but about politics.
第二幕，“法案如何成为——总统”，一位主要总统竞选活动的媒体秘书解释了那些不关乎爱情，而关乎政治的暗恋动力。
Act Three, On Seeing the 100% Perfect Girl One April Morning, in which one lonely crushee finally figures out what it was that he wanted to say-- what we all want to say as the person of our dreams passes us on the street. Stay with us.
第三幕，“四月的一个清晨见到百分之百的完美女孩”，一个孤独的暗恋者终于弄清楚了他想表达什么——那是当梦中情人与我们擦肩而过时，我们所有人都想说的话。请继续收听。
Act One, Kiss. So what if you held onto a high school crush? Under what conditions would it never go away? Tobias Wolff has this short story.
第一幕，“吻”。如果你一直守着高中的暗恋对象会怎样？在什么情况下它会永远挥之不去？托拜厄斯·沃尔夫带来了这个短篇故事。
When Joe Reed was a boy of 15, his craziness over a girl became such a burden to his family, and such a curiosity to the small town where they lived, that his mother threatened to pack him off to his married sister in San Diego. But before this could happen, Joe's father died, and his mother collected a large sum from Northwestern Mutual and sold the family pharmacy and moved both Joe and herself to California.
当乔·里德15岁时，他对一个女孩的痴迷成为了家庭的负担，也成了他们居住的小镇上的奇谈，以至于他的母亲威胁要把他送到圣地亚哥去投奔他已婚的姐姐。但在这件事发生之前，乔的父亲去世了，母亲从西北互助人寿保险公司拿到了一大笔赔偿金，卖掉了家里的药店，带着乔搬到了加利福尼亚。
30 years passed. In that time, he heard nothing from the girl, Mary Claude Moore, but now and then, word of her reached him through people back in Dunston. She dropped out of high school in her senior year, had a baby, got married, got divorced, remarried a few years later. That second marriage was the last thing Joe learned about Mary Claude until he got the news of her death.
30年过去了。那段时间，他没有收到任何关于那个女孩玛丽·克劳德·摩尔的消息，但偶尔会通过邓斯顿的老相识听到一些关于她的传闻。她大四那年退学了，生了个孩子，结了婚，离了婚，几年后又再婚了。那次再婚是乔在得知玛丽·克劳德死讯前，最后一次听到的关于她的消息。
He dropped by his mother's house one Sunday afternoon. They had coffee together. And that was when she told him about Mary Claude and gave him the letter. He didn't want to be thinking about what his reaction looked like, or ought to look like, so he excused himself and took the letter outside to the backyard.
一个周日的下午，他顺道去了母亲家。他们一起喝了咖啡。就在那时，母亲告诉了他玛丽·克劳德的事，并把那封信给了他。他不想去想自己的反应看起来像什么，或者应该看起来像什么，于是他找了个借口，带着信去了后院。
According to the newspaper clipping his mother's friend had enclosed, Mary Claude appeared to have fallen asleep at the wheel and drifted into the oncoming lane of traffic. She'd been killed outright, and so had the driver of the car she hit, a dentist from Bellingham on his way home from a weekend of fishing.
根据母亲朋友附上的剪报，玛丽·克劳德似乎是在开车时睡着了，漂移到了对面车道。她当场死亡，被她撞上的那辆车的司机也死了，那是一名从贝灵汉钓鱼归来的牙医。
That was the newspaper account. The unofficial version, which his mother's friend disparaged but passed along anyway, was that Mary Claude had been having a fling with a real estate agent named Chip Ryan. Chip Ryan drove the same unusual car as the dentist, a red Mercedes station wagon. And Mary Claude had an equally distinctive old Mustang convertible, powder blue.
那是报纸上的报道。而非官方版本，尽管被母亲的朋友所不屑但还是传了出来，是说玛丽·克劳德与一位名叫奇普·瑞安的房产中介有一段情。奇普·瑞安开着和那位牙医一样的罕见车型，一辆红色梅赛德斯旅行车。而玛丽·克劳德则有一辆同样显眼的旧款粉蓝色野马敞篷车。
Both of them lived outside town and frequently passed each other coming and going. The story was, whenever they met on an empty stretch of road, they played a game where they switched lanes at the last moment, a sort of lovers game. Mary Claude had mistaken the dentist's car for Chip's, and that was that.
他们都住在镇外，经常在来往时路过对方。传闻说，每当他们在空旷的路上相遇，他们就会玩一种游戏，在最后一刻变换车道，这是一种恋人间的游戏。玛丽·克劳德把牙医的车误认为是奇普的车，事情就是这样。
Joe could hardly make sense of the story. His mother's friend doubted it was true, but conceded that it certainly was a puzzle, how Mary Claude could've fallen asleep just 100 feet past a series of tight curves. Still, she wrote, there were probably other ways of explaining it without insulting her memory and giving needless pain to her family. She was survived by her husband, three children, and two grandchildren. For some reason, the paper hadn't run a picture of her with the piece. Joe was glad of the omission.
乔几乎无法理解这个故事。母亲的朋友怀疑这是真的，但承认这确实是个谜，玛丽·克劳德怎么会在刚过了一连串急转弯后100英尺的地方就睡着了呢。不过她写道，可能还有其他的解释方式，而不必侮辱她的名声并给她的家人带来不必要的痛苦。她身后留下了丈夫、三个孩子和两个孙辈。出于某种原因，报纸上并没有刊登她的照片。乔对这一疏漏感到庆幸。
Joe had lived another submerged life, parallel to the one known to those around him. In this other life, he hadn't left for California but had stayed on in Dunston with Mary Claude. He fell into this dream during the first months after the move in the immensity of summer, on a sun-struck street full of old geezers, where sprinklers ran at night on lawns visited only by the Mexicans who mowed them.
乔过着另一种隐秘的生活，与周围人所知的生活平行。在那另一种生活中，他没有去加利福尼亚，而是留在了邓斯顿，和玛丽·克劳德在一起。搬家后的最初几个月，在漫长的夏天里，他陷入了这个梦境，在一条满是老人的阳光照耀下的街道上，夜里只有修剪草坪的墨西哥人才会光顾的草坪上，喷水装置在嗡嗡作响。
When his mother left her darkened bedroom long enough to chase him outside, Joe took the Saturday Evening Post to a pool in a nearby park and watched the girls oil each other and arch their glistening legs over their backs and shriek when loitering thugs threw water on them. He lay on his stomach and stared at the Post and lived his ghost life with Mary Claude.
当母亲离开黑暗的卧室赶他出门时，乔就拿着《周六晚报》去附近公园的游泳池，看着女孩们互相涂抹防晒油，将闪亮的双腿拱起搭在背上，当路过的流氓向她们泼水时发出尖叫。他趴在草地上盯着报纸，和玛丽·克劳德过着他的幻影生活。
After Joe started school, his mother took a job as an accountant for an office furniture store. A few months later, she and another woman formed a partnership and bought the owner out. Joe's mother began to dress smartly. She wore her hair straight instead of piled up on her head and let a gray streak show through. One night at dinner, she called "Joe" in such a way he realized she'd been speaking to him without his knowing it. And when he looked at her, she said, "You can't bring him back, son. You have to let him go." Joe was embarrassed at the depth of her misunderstanding, but he played along. He let her think she'd read his mind.
乔开始上学后，母亲在一家办公家具店找到了一份会计工作。几个月后，她和另一位女士合伙买下了店主手里的股份。乔的母亲开始打扮得干练起来。她不再把头发盘在头顶，而是把头发拉直，并让灰白的发丝显露出来。一天晚餐时，她喊了声“乔”，乔意识到她在他不知情的情况下已经跟他说了半天话了。当他看着她时，她说：“你没法把他带回来，孩子。你得让他过去。”乔对她这种深刻的误解感到尴尬，但他顺着她的话演了下去。他让她以为她看穿了自己的心事。
The high school was new and bright and vast. In the echoing hallways, the voices of the students mingled in a roar that Joe came to hear as an aspect of the silence in which he passed his days. He sometimes went home without having spoken a word to anyone. It seemed to him that he might go through the whole year that way, and the next year too, until he graduated. But before long, he became friends with his biology lab partner, who took him to parties and introduced him to girls.
这所高中又新又明亮且广阔。在回响的走廊里，学生们的谈话声汇成一阵喧嚣，乔开始将其视为他度过时日的那种寂静的一部分。他有时回家时没对任何人说过一句话。他觉得他可能会就这样过完这一年，下一年也一样，直到毕业。但没过多久，他和生物实验室的伙伴成了朋友，对方带他去参加派对，并向他介绍了女孩。
When Joe got his driver's license that spring, he began to date Carla. He aced his courses and played Officer Krupke in West Side Story . In the fall of his senior year, he and Carla left a dance early and went to a motel. It was the first time for both of them and a failure. They tried again a few days later in Carla's bedroom and had better luck.
那年春天，乔拿到驾照后开始和卡拉约会。他课程成绩优异，还在《西区故事》里演了克鲁普克警官。大四那年秋天，他和卡拉早早离场，去了一家汽车旅馆。那是他们俩的第一次，结果却是一场失败。几天后他们在卡拉的卧室里再次尝试，运气好了一些。
And by Christmas, Joe was starting to see Courtney on the sly. He didn't really prefer her, but it seemed inevitable that sooner or later, either he or Carla would be unfaithful, and he wanted to be the one.
到了圣诞节，乔开始悄悄和考特尼来往。他其实并不更偏爱她，但似乎迟早他和卡拉之间总有一个人会不忠，他想做那个不忠的人。
It turned out to be much more complicated than he'd thought. Joe was soon exposed and denounced by both girls as a heartless cheat, which did not, it turned out, entirely discourage other girls from going out with him. And through all this, he continued his phantom life with Mary Claude. He was with her on a blanket in a moonlit clearing, or in a car parked above the river with Ray Charles on the radio, her fingertips grazing the back of his neck, her mouth open to his, her caramel taste on his lips and tongue and deep in his throat.
事情证明比他想象的要复杂得多。乔很快被两个女孩揭发并谴责为无情的骗子，但这并没有完全阻止其他女孩和他约会。尽管如此，他依然继续着他和玛丽·克劳德的幻影生活。他在月光下的空地上和她铺着毯子，或者在停在河边的车里，收音机里放着雷·查尔斯的歌，她的指尖掠过他的后颈，她的嘴唇贴向他，她的焦糖味留在他嘴唇和舌尖，并深入他的喉咙。
Only the kiss was a memory. Only the kiss was real. He'd hardly been anywhere with Mary Claude, except when they could sneak off at school and a few times in town. But from the kiss, he made everything else, or everything else made itself.
只有那个吻是记忆。只有那个吻是真实的。他和玛丽·克劳德几乎没去过什么地方，除了在学校偷偷溜走的那几次和镇上的几次。但从那个吻开始，他创造了一切，或者说一切自然而然地发生了。
For that was how it happened. Without any effort of imagination or sense of unreality, he watched his life with Mary Claude go on as he had once believed it would. The scenes grew more particular as time passed, each new one framed by those that had gone before, and always with a kiss at the heart of it.
事情就是这样发生的。没有丝毫的想象力或虚幻感，他看着他和玛丽·克劳德的生活像他曾经相信的那样继续下去。随着时间的推移，场景变得愈发具体，每一个新场景都由前一个场景串联起来，且核心始终是一个吻。
At Berkeley, Joe went with Maureen. And when Maureen left for a year at the Sorbonne, there was Linda, then Candace. He and Candace shared a house with two other couples until they graduated. And afterward, they rented an apartment of their own through Joe's first year of medical school. Then Candace went to New York to visit her family and never came back. She sent Joe a letter in which she asked his forgiveness for the problems she'd caused through her alcoholism, which she was now in the process of confronting. She said she couldn't return to the life she'd led in Berkeley, as he must understand.
在伯克利，乔和莫琳交往。后来莫琳去索邦大学待了一年，接着是琳达，然后是坎迪丝。他和坎迪丝在毕业前一直和另外两对伴侣合租一栋房子。后来，他们在乔上医学院的第一年里租了一套自己的公寓。再后来，坎迪丝去纽约看望家人，就再也没回来。她给乔寄来一封信，请求他原谅她因酗酒而造成的问题，她现在正在面对这个问题。她说她无法回到她在伯克利过的那种生活，他一定能理解。
No, Joe did not understand. They'd had their troubles, the two of them. He'd been going all out, and so had Candace, waitressing nights as she worked toward a degree in dance therapy. Of course, there were problems, but nothing that serious. He certainly didn't begrudge her a little relaxation. But when Joe's mother heard about Candace leaving, the first thing she said was that she hoped she'd get some help for her drinking. Joe hadn't mentioned the letter.
不，乔不理解。他们之间有过摩擦，他俩都有过。他全力以赴，坎迪丝也一样，一边做服务生，一边攻读舞蹈治疗学位。当然，是有问题，但没那么严重。他当然不会计较她偶尔放松一下。但当乔的母亲听说坎迪丝离开时，她说的第一句话是希望她能为酗酒寻求帮助。乔没提过那封信的事。
By the time he started his residency in Seattle, he'd entered a state of near quarantine that made his shadow life more moony and detailed than ever.
当他在西雅图开始实习医生生涯时，他进入了一种近乎隔离的状态，这让他的影子生活比以往任何时候都更加梦幻和详尽。
Dunston was just three hours north of Seattle. Joe sometimes thought of driving up on a free afternoon but never did. By then, he'd heard that Mary Claude was married again. There was no purpose in making the trip except to see her, and he was afraid that she wouldn't want to see him, and also afraid that she would. It was too late for that. She had a daughter and a husband and a house to run. She had work to do.
邓斯顿就在西雅图以北三小时路程的地方。乔有时想在空闲的下午开车去看看，但从来没去过。那时，他听说玛丽·克劳德又结婚了。除了去见她之外，此行没有任何目的，而他害怕她不想见他，也害怕她会想见他。已经太迟了。她有女儿、有丈夫，还要打理一个家。她有自己的工作要做。
So did he. Useful, exacting work. It depended on a clarity Joe knew he couldn't rely on, that he had to improvise day by day. He'd lost it before, and could not risk losing it again.
他也是。既有用又严苛的工作。它取决于一种乔知道自己无法依赖的清晰感，这种清晰感他必须每天临场发挥。他以前失去过它，不敢再冒失去它的风险。
When Mary Claude was killed, Joe had been married for 17 years. His wife, Liz, was a pediatrician in the same clinic where he practiced as an internist. They had a son in his junior year of high school, a daughter a year younger. The boy was a gifted cellist, unworldly, dreamy. Joe's daughter was more calculating but fiercer in her attachments once she'd made them. Joe began taking her rock climbing when she was still in grade school, and she turned out to be the most fearless and inventive partner he'd ever had.
玛丽·克劳德去世时，乔已经结婚17年了。他的妻子利兹和他在同一家诊所担任内科医生。他们有一个读高二的儿子，一个比他小一岁的女儿。男孩是个天才大提琴手，不谙世事，充满幻想。乔的女儿则更精明，一旦投入感情就会变得非常热烈。乔从她读小学起就开始带她去攀岩，她最终成了他见过的最无畏、最有创造力的搭档。
Then came a time when his daughter ceased to confide. Both daughter and son developed private sources of amusement, and Joe began to detect a certain condescension in their handling of him. His children were slipping away into the deep forest. He tried not to hurry them with the panic he felt at the gathering signs of their departure.
后来，女儿不再向他倾诉了。儿子和女儿都有了各自的私人娱乐，乔开始察觉到他们对待他时带有一种某种优越感。他的孩子们正溜向森林深处。他尽量不表现出自己在见到他们离去的迹象时感到的恐慌，也不想催促他们。
Liz, too, kept changing on him. When they first met, she was girlish and unsure of herself in spite of being three years older than Joe. But since then, she'd grown calm and regal, which both unsettled and excited him. In their lovemaking, he approached her almost wistfully, and sometimes concluded with a bark of triumph, as if he'd brought a notorious virgin to ground. Away from her for more than a day or two, Joe hardly knew who he was.
利兹也在不断改变。他们刚认识时，尽管利兹比乔大三岁，但她还是充满少女气且对自己不自信。但从那以后，她变得冷静而庄重，这既让他不安又让他兴奋。在他们的性生活中，他几乎是以一种渴望的姿态接近她，有时还会带着一声胜利的叫喊结束，仿佛他把一个著名的处女降服了一样。只要离开她超过一两天，乔几乎就不知道自己是谁了。
And still, through all these years, he had thoughts of Mary Claude. He thought of Mary Claude sitting across from him at a table in the kitchen, barely awake, drinking coffee. He thought of them standing on a porch and waving as friends drove off. And when they were alone, Mary Claude turned to him and slipped an arm around his waist. And they went slowly inside and up the stairs, stopping to kiss on the landing.
尽管如此，这些年来，他仍常会想起玛丽·克劳德。他想到玛丽·克劳德坐在厨房桌子对面，还没完全醒透，喝着咖啡。他想到他们站在门廊上，挥手送别朋友离去。当他们独处时，玛丽·克劳德转过身，将手臂滑向他的腰部。他们慢慢地走进屋里，沿着楼梯往上走，在楼梯口停下来接吻。
Sometimes, Joe thought of what was to follow, but this was the moment he lingered on. The kiss. Joe remembered very well what it was like to kiss Mary Claude. He had done it as much as anyone could for as long as they were going together, which came to just over three months.
有时，乔会想接下来会发生什么，但他总是留恋那个时刻。那个吻。乔记得很清楚吻玛丽·克劳德是什么感觉。在他们交往的三个月多一点的时间里，他尽可能多地吻过她。
Mary Claude's father owned a dairy farm several miles out of town. Her mother had moved away when Mary Claude was 11, taking her daughter with her. She married again, but things did not go well between her daughter and this new husband, and she sent Mary Claude back to her father when she was 15. Joe had gone through the first six years of grade school barely noticing her, drab little hick that she was.
玛丽·克劳德的父亲在镇外几英里处拥有一家奶牛场。她母亲在玛丽·克劳德11岁时就搬走了，带着女儿一起。她再婚了，但女儿和这位新继父相处得并不好，于是她在玛丽·克劳德15岁时把她送回了父亲那里。乔在小学的前六年里几乎没注意到她，她那时是个土里土气的小村姑。
But she came back a different girl, witchy and vivid. She mouthed off to the teachers and walked around in a pout with her back arched like a bow. She had no friends except for an equally friendless cousin. During volleyball games in her gym class, she baited the other girls by deliberately hitting the ball lot of bounds or into the net. She cut classes and smoked and made out with other girls' boyfriends, or so it was said.
但她回来时像换了个人，妖娆而生动。她对老师顶嘴，走起路来嘟着嘴，背拱得像一张弓。除了一个同样没朋友的表亲，她没有朋友。在体育课的排球比赛中，她故意把球打出界或打进网里来戏弄其他女孩。她逃课、抽烟，还和别人的男朋友亲热，据说是这样。
And Joe, curious to test the rumor, found it to be true. Mary Claude went behind the school with him, during a dance to which he'd brought another girl, and kept him out there for over an hour. He knew she was doing it to shame his date, at first anyway, until she warmed to him. But once he started, he couldn't stop kissing her.
乔出于好奇想验证一下谣言，发现是真的。在一次舞会上，乔带了另一个女孩，但玛丽·克劳德躲在学校后面把他拉过去，让他待了一个多小时。起初，他知道她这么做是为了让他的舞伴难堪，直到她对他有了兴致。但一旦开始，他就无法停止吻她。
Joe had, by then, kissed several girls and thought he had a pretty fair idea of the possibilities of a kiss. Kissing was good. But he tended to think of it as a beachhead from which to launch more serious operations, and a safe haven when, inevitably, he was forced to retreat. But he didn't remember to try anything else that night, leaning against the gymnasium wall with this girl, who tasted so good and pressed so fully against him, humming in his ear when they stopped to breathe and swaying to the music that rattled the high windows above them.
乔在那之前已经吻过几个女孩，自认为对亲吻的各种可能相当了解。接吻的感觉很好。但他往往把接吻看作是发动更严重行动的滩头堡，或者当他不可避免地被迫撤退时的安全港。但那天晚上，靠在健身房的墙上，面对这个味道如此美好、身体紧紧贴着他、在他们停下来喘息时在他耳边哼唱、随着头顶震动高窗的音乐摇摆的女孩，他甚至没想起要尝试别的什么。
There were other couples along the wall, and Joe knew his date would hear about this. But when he started to lean away, Mary Claude laid her fingers along his cheeks and guided his mouth back to hers. And after that, he forgot leaving. He would have stayed there all night with no sense of time passing, but finally, a girl came out and told Mary Claude that her ride was waiting to take her home. She turned to go, then stopped and kissed Joe again. He walked around the school twice before going back inside. The gym was almost empty. His date had left with friends.
墙边还有其他情侣，乔知道他的舞伴会听到风声。但当他开始向后倾斜时，玛丽·克劳德把手指搭在他的脸颊上，引导他的嘴回到她嘴上。在那之后，他忘了离开。他本可以在那里待上一整晚，完全没有时间流逝的感觉，但最后，一个女孩走出来告诉玛丽·克劳德，接她回家的车到了。她转身离开，又停下来再次吻了乔。他在学校周围走了两圈才回到室内。健身房里几乎空无一人。他的舞伴已经和朋友们离开了。
When he saw Mary Claude in the hallway on Monday morning, he did not pretend that nothing had happened, nor did she. She'd let him take her books and walk her to class. At the lunch period, they went to the cafeteria and sat across from each other. He understood what would happen, the hush around them, how they'd looked at, even by his friends. Joe knew the rules. He'd been a [BLEEP] and hurt a nice girl. And for Mary Claude, of all people. You could make out with Mary Claude, but you had to laugh about it later and cut her dead.
周一早上在走廊见到玛丽·克劳德时，他没装作什么都没发生，她也没有。她让他拿上她的书，陪她去上课。午饭时间，他们去了食堂，面对面坐着。他明白会发生什么，周围的寂静，甚至他朋友们投来的目光。乔知道规则。他是个混蛋，伤害了一个好女孩。而且还是为了玛丽·克劳德。你可以和玛丽·克劳德亲热，但你之后必须对此大加嘲笑，并彻底冷落她。
They ate without talking. Her color was high. Otherwise, she gave nothing away. She helped herself to his carrots, and that was that. They were a pair.
他们沉默地吃着东西。她脸色红润。除此之外，她什么都没表现出来。她顺手拿走了他的胡萝卜，事情就是这样。他们成了一对。
There was a fern-choked gully behind the school. There were the stands by the football field, empty classrooms. She tasted of lipstick and cigarettes and candy. Which she opened her mouth to his, the first sensation was a shock of relief as the tightness melted in a rush from his neck and shoulders. And then, he was swaying with her, drinking that smoky sweetness, drinking forgetfulness of the schoolwork he had not done, the stammer he was developing, his mother dazed and pale, the room at the end of the hallway where his father lay gasping for the next breath like a trout dropped on the river bank.
学校后面有一条长满蕨类植物的深沟。足球场边有看台，还有空旷的教室。她嘴里有口红、香烟和糖的味道。当她向他张开嘴时，第一感觉是一种如释重负的冲击，他脖子和肩膀的紧绷感瞬间消融。接着，他与她一起摇摆，饮下那烟熏般的甜蜜，饮下对他没完成功课、他正在形成的结巴、他那迷茫而苍白的母亲、以及他父亲躺在走廊尽头房间里像被扔在河岸上的鳟鱼一样喘息的遗忘。
He forgot to plan what to try next, where to touch, how hard to press. He stopped thinking ahead. There was no ahead, no before, and no after. He was itchy with thirst and deeply satisfied all at once.
他忘了计划下一步该做什么，该摸哪里，该用力多大。他停止了预想。没有未来，没有过去，也没有将来。他口渴难耐，却又同时感到深深的满足。
And Mary Claude was thirsty for him. He'd never have this happened before, a girl impatient for the taste of him, greedy for it. She did not like to break off. When he leaned away for a breath, she would close her fingers in his hair and pull him back to her. She sometimes said his name in a low, almost mocking way, and the sound of it whipped him around is if she'd yanked on a leash.
而玛丽·克劳德也渴求着他。他从未见过这种情况，一个女孩迫不及待地想要他的味道，对此如饥似渴。她不喜欢中断。当他倾身喘气时，她会用手指抓紧他的头发，把他拉回身边。她有时会用一种低沉、近乎嘲弄的口吻叫他的名字，那声音鞭打着他，仿佛她拉紧了拴狗的链子。
Mary Claude some grew careless with their privacy. She didn't care who saw them or when. She'd command a kiss-- a profound kiss-- as she boarded her bus, or in the hallway, even on the street in town when her father let her go in for some shopping after school. Joe knew that it went beyond carelessness, that she was making a display of their appetite, perhaps especially of his appetite for her. He could see that she was proud of her claim on him, and this made him proud and brazen too. He didn't mind if people thought they were ridiculous, even a sort of joke, the two of them stitched together at the mouth, as his mother put it.
玛丽·克劳德后来对他们的私密变得不那么在意了。她不在乎谁会看到，也不在乎什么时候。她在上校车时，或在走廊里，甚至在放学后她父亲让她进城购物时的街上，都会索要一个吻——一个深刻的吻。乔知道这不仅是粗心，她在炫耀他们的欲望，尤其是他对她的欲望。他能看出她为自己对他拥有的掌控力感到骄傲，这让他也感到自豪和大胆。他不介意别人觉得他们可笑，甚至把他们当笑话，正如他母亲所说，他们两个是嘴对嘴缝在一起的。
Joe's mother had heard about them. She heard everything in the pharmacy. At first, she came at him aslant about it. Then she lost patience. Was this the time to be carrying on with some girl? Couldn't he sit with his father a while instead of mooning in his room and tying up the telephone? Would that be too much to ask? Joe knew he should care that he was giving his mother trouble, but nothing she said touched him. It wasn't out of concern for her that he ruined everything.
乔的母亲听说过他们。她在药店里什么都能听到。起初，她侧面敲击地问过他。后来她失去了耐心。这是和某个女孩鬼混的时候吗？他能不能多陪陪他父亲，而不是在他房间里发呆和占用电话？这难道要求过分吗？乔知道他应该在意自己给母亲惹了麻烦，但她所说的一切都触动不了他。他弄砸一切并非出于对她的担忧。
He and Mary Claude were in the stands during a basketball game. She was bored. She wanted to leave, go outside. Joe kept putting her off. The game was close. She started to play with the hair at the nape of his neck. He liked the feeling, and almost surrendered to it, but something came over him, and he shrugged her hand off. He felt Mary Claude go still beside him. He knew she was looking at him, but he kept his eyes on the players, and even produced a shout when one of them goofed a pass.
他和玛丽·克劳德在篮球比赛期间坐在看台上。她无聊了。她想离开，去外面。乔一直搪塞她。比赛正处于关键时刻。她开始玩弄他后颈的头发。他喜欢这种感觉，差点就屈服了，但某种情绪袭上心头，他耸肩甩开了她的手。他感觉到玛丽·克劳德在他身边静止了。他知道她在看着他，但他保持视线盯着球员，甚至在其中一人传球失误时还喊了一声。
Mary Claude slid her fingers back into his hair, tightened them, and began to turn his head toward hers. Without taking his eyes from the game, he gave a rough shake and pulled away. Mary Claude stood up, but waited there a moment. And though Joe knew he could still turn to her, even then, he did not.
玛丽·克劳德将手指插回他的头发，用力抓紧，开始转动他的头使其转向自己。他不看比赛，粗暴地摇了摇头并甩开了她。玛丽·克劳德站起身，但在那里等了一会儿。尽管乔知道即使在那时他依然可以转向她，但他没有。
She made her way to the aisle. He watched her descend the steps and cross in front of the stands and leave the gym. The game had become meaningless to him, but he sat through the rest of it. His mouth was dry. His heart thudded as if it were hollow.
她走向过道。他看着她走下台阶，从看台前穿过，离开了健身房。比赛对他来说已经变得毫无意义，但他还是坐着看完了剩下的部分。他嘴里发干。他的心脏砰砰作响，仿佛空空如也。
Tobias Wolff's story continues, plus other stories, in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
托拜厄斯·沃尔夫的故事待会儿继续，更多故事，来自国际公共广播电台，我们的节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different stories on that theme. Today's program, for Valentine's Day, Crushes. What's good about them, what's terrible about them, what happens when they take over your life. Tobias Wolff continues with his short story, "Kiss."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种不同的相关故事。今天是为了情人节准备的“暗恋”主题。它们有什么好，有什么可怕，以及当它们占据你的生活时会发生什么。托拜厄斯·沃尔夫继续为您讲述他的短篇故事《吻》。
Joe phoned Mary Claude when he got home, but no one answered. He called again just before he went to bed, and someone picked up but didn't say anything. "Mary Claude," he said. "Mary Claude, please."
乔回家后打电话给玛丽·克劳德，但没人接。他在睡觉前又打了一次，有人接了，但什么也没说。“玛丽·克劳德，”他说。“玛丽·克劳德，求求你。”
She wouldn't answer. He knew she was waiting for him to give an account, to justify himself, and he couldn't think what to say. In the end, all he could say was her name, "Mary Claude," and then she hung up.
她不回答。他知道她在等他给出一个解释，为自己辩解，但他不知道该说什么。最后，他只能叫她的名字，“玛丽·克劳德”，然后她挂断了电话。
She hung up whenever he called. He pushed notes into her locker and got no answer. He met her bus every morning, and she walked right past him. He waited outside her classrooms and followed her down the hall and out to the bus stop after school. He knew he was making a fool of himself, but he had no choice. There was no other way to be close to her.
每次他打电话，她都挂断。他把纸条塞进她的储物柜，没得到回应。他每天早上等她的校车，她却径直从他身边走过。他在教室外等她，跟着她走过走廊，放学后跟到巴士站。他知道自己在自取其辱，但他别无选择。没有其他方法可以接近她。
His mother heard about it and demanded that he leave the girl alone. It made no difference. Joe continued to trail Mary Claude. And still, Mary Claude did not relent.
他母亲听说了这件事，要求他离那个女孩远点。毫无作用。乔继续跟踪玛丽·克劳德。然而，玛丽·克劳德并没有回心转意。
They had one class together. Washington State history. She sat two seats ahead of him in the next row to the left. He could watch Mary Claude without seeing him watch her, though of course, she knew. He was alert to any movement that allowed him a view of Mary Claude's mouth. She often turned to look at the clock over the door, and Joe never failed to seize that glint of her face in profile, the high forehead, the full mouth. When he saw her mouth, he leaned forward, narrowing the distance by at least that much.
他们有一门共同的课程，华盛顿州历史。她坐在他前面左侧的第二排。他可以看着玛丽·克劳德而不让她察觉到他在看她，尽管当然，她心知肚明。他留意着任何能让他看到玛丽·克劳德嘴部的动作。她经常转头看门上的时钟，乔从不放过那一闪而过的侧脸，那高挺的额头，那饱满的嘴唇。当他看到她的嘴时，他会倾身向前，至少缩短了那么一点距离。
It was wrong that he couldn't put his mouth to hers. It was an impossible mistake that kept him baffled and on edge. She must be feeling what he was feeling. Joe was sure of that. If he was cut off from her, she was cut off from him. She was in exile too. But it went on and on. And Joe came to understand that Mary Claude didn't know how to end it, that she was waiting for him to find a way. But what could he do when she wouldn't speak to him, when she wouldn't even look at him?
不能吻她是错误的。这是一个让他困惑并处于边缘的荒谬错误。她一定能感受到他所感受到的。乔对此深信不疑。如果他被隔绝在她的世界之外，她也一样被隔绝。她也处于流亡之中。但这种情况持续了很久。乔开始明白，玛丽·克劳德不知道如何结束这一切，她在等他想出办法。但当她不跟他说话，甚至连看都不看他时，他能做什么呢？
Then she began keeping company with Al Dodge. Al was a senior, a quiet, well-liked boy who struggled in school and had a limp from polio. He lived just up the road from Mary Claude. He drove to school, and Mary Claude started riding with him instead of taking the bus. They often ate lunch together.
接着她开始和阿尔·道奇来往。阿尔是个大四学生，一个安静、受欢迎的男孩，在学校学习吃力，且因小儿麻痹症而跛脚。他住在玛丽·克劳德家往上那条路。他开车上学，玛丽·克劳德开始坐他的车，而不是坐校车了。他们经常一起吃午饭。
Joe was confused at first. Then he saw that this was his signal. He waited for Al outside the wood shop and begin to tell him about Mary Claude and himself, but Al wouldn't listen. He tried to brush past, but Joe wasn't through talking and blocked his way. Al pushed at him, and his bad leg gave out, and he went down, his metal brace clattering on the concrete.
乔起初很困惑。然后他意识到这是给他的信号。他在木工教室外等阿尔，开始告诉他关于他和玛丽·克劳德的事，但阿尔不听。他试图擦身而过，但乔还没说完，挡住了他的去路。阿尔推了他一下，他那条残疾的腿支撑不住，倒了下去，金属支架在水泥地上发出刺耳的声音。
Joe bent to help him up, but two boys ran over and shouldered him aside. One of them gave Joe a look as he struggled to lift Al to his feet. Joe wanted to explain everything, and the impossibility of ever doing this left him no choice but to smile at the boy and tell him to go [BLEEP] himself.
乔弯腰去扶他，但两个男孩跑过来把他推到一边。其中一个人在乔努力拉阿尔站起来时瞪了他一眼。乔想解释清楚，但他深知要解释这一切根本不可能，这让他别无选择，只能朝那个男孩一笑，让他滚去吃屎。
He could see when he got home that his mother already knew about it. She sent him to work in the store and spoke to him only when she had to. While he was doing the dishes that night, she came to the kitchen and told him that his sister and her husband were willing to have Joe come live with them until things got sorted out. Until his father died, Joe took her to mean.
回家后，他看出母亲已经知道这件事了。她让他去店里干活，只有不得已时才和他说话。那天晚上他在洗碗时，母亲走进厨房，告诉他，他的姐姐和姐夫愿意让乔去和他们同住，直到事情平息下来。乔把她的话理解为在他父亲去世之前。
Her face was flushed, her eyes brilliant. She stood erect in the doorway and forced him to look at her. She was magnificent, and he resented it. Did he want to go to San Diego? Did he want to do that? No? Was he sure? All right, she said. She needed him here. But one more thing like this, he'd be on the first bus out of town. Did he understand? Good.
她的脸涨红了，眼睛闪闪发光。她挺直地站在门口，逼着他看着她。她很壮美，而他心生怨恨。他想去圣地亚哥吗？他想这样做吗？不想？确定吗？好吧，她说。她需要他留在这儿。但再发生一次这种事，他就会坐上离开小镇的第一班车。他明白了吗？很好。
Now she wanted Joe to go to his father and make the same promise to him. Joe did no such thing. He listened to the weird submarine clankings emanating from his father's oxygen tank, and studied the pattern in the rug, and answered a few wheezy questions about his schoolwork, and then he got the hell out of there, but not before his father put his dry, yellow hand on Joe's wrist and pulled him down into an embrace that left him sick with horror.
现在她要乔去找他父亲，并向他做出同样的承诺。乔才没做这种事。他听着从父亲氧气瓶里发出的怪异的潜水艇般的哐当声，研究着地毯的纹路，回答了几个关于他功课的喘息问题，然后就该死的离开了那里。但在离开前，他父亲用那只干燥、发黄的手抓住乔的手腕，把他拽进一个拥抱中，那让他感到一阵恐怖的恶心。
He stopped following Mary Claude to her classes. She rode to school with Al Dodge, and they sometimes ate together, but Joe could see there was nothing between them. She was alone, as before. So was Joe, more than ever, the guy who picked on cripples. He didn't follow Mary Claude, but he watched her, from nearby when he could, but mostly from a distance, cocking her hip to hold her locker door open, at a cafeteria table, tearing at the peel of an orange with her strong, white fingers.
他停止了跟踪玛丽·克劳德去上课。她坐阿尔·道奇的车上学，他们有时一起吃饭，但乔看得出来他们之间什么都没有。她像以前一样孤独。乔也是，而且比以往任何时候都孤独，成了那个欺负残疾人的家伙。他不跟踪玛丽·克劳德，但他关注着她，能近距离时就近距离，但大多数时候保持距离，看着她歪着胯撑开储物柜门，在食堂桌子边，用强壮洁白的手指撕开橙子皮。
It was late May. In a couple of weeks, school would be over, and he'd have no way of breaking the spell he had brought on them. He decided he would kiss her. She was like him. After the first taste, she always wanted another, and then another, until she lost herself. That was what they needed, to lose themselves again.
那时是五月下旬。再过几周，学校就要放假了，他将无法打破他给他们带来的魔咒。他决定要吻她。她和他一样。尝过第一次后，她总是想要再来一次，然后又一次，直到她迷失自我。这就是他们所需要的，再次迷失自我。
Mary Claude's gym teacher took the girls outside on warm days for softball and track. Joe's French class met that period, but he sometimes cut out early to stand in the shade of the trees at the near end of the field and watch Mary Claude. When the teacher led the class back inside, Mary Claude always made a point of lagging far behind, as if the force that impelled the others had no hold on her.
玛丽·克劳德的体育老师在天气暖和的时候会带女孩们去户外练习垒球和田径。乔的那节课刚好是法语课，但他有时会提前溜出来，站在场边树荫下看着玛丽·克劳德。当老师带班级回室内时，玛丽·克劳德总是特意落在最后，仿佛驱使他人的那股力量对她毫无作用。
He stood under a horse-chestnut tree beside the path that led to the locker rooms. The tree was in bloom. Eyes had gone weepy and raw from the pollen. When she drew near to him, he spoke her name and she looked up without surprise. He'd had something all planned out to say, but now that he was close to her, he forgot what it was. The whiteness of her legs emptied him of words. She waited, arms still crossed. Then she said, "You been crying?"
他站在通往更衣室路径旁的一棵七叶树下。树正开着花。他的眼睛因花粉而变得酸涩。当她走近他时，他叫了她的名字，她抬头看他，并无惊讶。他本想好了该说什么，但现在近距离面对她，他忘了是什么话。她那洁白的双腿让他脑中一片空白。她等待着，双臂依然交叉。然后她说：“你一直在哭吗？”
Joe wasn't sure what happened next. Even right after it happened, he had no confidence in any account, even in his own memory, and had accepted the blame that fell on him without protest and without belief. But he knew that it started with Mary Claude's crack about his eyes. He heard her mockery as forgiveness. Forgiveness and summons. It sent a rush of heat to his face. He could still feel it, thinking back.
乔不确定接下来发生了什么。即使事后，他也无法确信任何陈述，甚至对自己记忆也不敢肯定，只能默默地承受着落在自己身上的指责，既无抗议也无确信。但他知道一切始于玛丽·克劳德关于他眼睛的嘲讽。他从她的嘲弄中听出了宽恕。宽恕与召唤。这让他的脸涨得通红。回想起来，他仍能感觉到那种热度。
Then he lost the thread. He remembered holding one of her hands in both of his, and her leaning away and looking at him. But struggling? Perhaps. Then he remembered being with her under the tree, his arms around her. But how they got there, he couldn't say. Maybe he led her there. Maybe he really did force her.
然后他失去了思绪。他记得用双手握住她的手，她向后倾斜并看着他。但挣扎了吗？也许吧。然后他记得自己和她在树下，双臂拥抱着她。但他们是怎么到那里的，他说不上来。也许是他带她去的。也许他真的强迫了她。
The one thing he was sure of was that her mouth was opening to his when the gym teacher grabbed his collar. Even as she wrenched him back, shirt front bunched at his throat, he was straining forward to seal the kiss. Then Mary Claude turned aside and started gagging and weeping, and he knew he'd have to start all over again.
唯一确定的是，当体育老师抓住他的衣领时，她的嘴正向他张开。即使在她把他拽回来，衬衫前襟团在一起勒住他的喉咙时，他依然努力向前想去封住那个吻。然后玛丽·克劳德转身走开，开始作呕并哭泣，他知道他必须一切从头再来。
He didn't argue with anything anyone said. His mother surprised him by trying to make the principal feel sorry for her, something he'd never seen her do. But it didn't pay off. The principal refused to let Joe finish out the year. As he was clearing out his locker, a couple of seniors walked past and made smooching sounds. And other students took it up as Joe carried his stuff down the hallway.
他没有反驳任何人的说法。他母亲试图让校长同情她，这让他很惊讶，他从未见过她那样做。但这没起到作用。校长拒绝让乔完成这一年的学业。当他清空储物柜时，几个大四学生走过，发出亲吻的声音。当乔扛着东西走过走廊时，其他学生也跟风效仿。
Joe's mother talked about sending him to San Diego that weekend. He'd made up his mind to refuse, but it never came to a test. Late Wednesday afternoon, his father went into a coma. Until he died that evening, Joe kept the watch with his mother, prowling the bedroom while his mother held her husband's hand. He was steady at his mother's side, gallant and grave.
乔的母亲谈到周末就把他送到圣地亚哥。他已下定决心拒绝，但没能等到那一步。周三深夜，他父亲陷入昏迷。直到那天晚上他去世，乔一直和母亲守在床边，在卧室里徘徊，而母亲握着丈夫的手。他坚定地守在母亲身边，既勇敢又庄重。
On the night after the funeral, he slipped downstairs and felt for the car keys on the hook where they were kept. Not there. Not there the next night either. So, his mother had second-guessed him. Joe was surprised that she had calculated so coolly in her grief. It made him think differently of her, better and worse.
葬礼后的第二天晚上，他溜下楼，摸索着挂钩上通常放着的车钥匙。不在那。第二天晚上也不在。所以，他母亲预判了他的行动。乔很惊讶她在悲痛中竟能算计得如此冷静。这让他对她的看法改变了，既变好了也变坏了。
Joe took the letter into his mother's yard and studied it a while. Hunched in a lawn chair, elbows on his knees, he waited to be struck. But down the street, someone was blasting a Strauss waltz through an open window. And he couldn't stop himself from following it, even conducting it with minute twitches of his head, though he'd lost his taste for old Vienna after Candace went on a Strauss binge the year before she left.
乔拿着信走进母亲的院子，研究了一会儿。他弓着身子坐在折叠椅上，手肘支在膝盖上，等待着某种冲击。但街对面，有人正通过敞开的窗户播放施特劳斯的圆舞曲。他忍不住跟着节奏，甚至用头部细微的抽动来指挥，尽管在坎迪丝离开前一年疯狂沉迷施特劳斯之后，他已经失去了对老维也纳音乐的兴趣。
The chair had looked dry when he sat down, but that morning's dew still lingered between the straps of webbing. It seeped into his pants, warm, clinging. The grass needed a trim. Joe knew that if he looked up, he'd see his mother watching him from the kitchen window, pulling a long face for what she imagined he was feeling. What he did feel was embarrassment at this hambone attempt to create sorrow by imitating it. Pathetic. Pathetic.
当他坐下时，椅子看起来很干，但那天早上的露水仍滞留在编织带之间。它渗进他的裤子里，温暖而粘腻。草坪需要修剪了。乔知道如果他抬头，会看到母亲从厨房窗户看着他，为她想象中他正在经历的悲伤拉长着脸。他感到的其实是这种模仿悲伤的拙劣表演带来的尴尬。可悲。可悲。
He rocked to his feet, looked sourly around as he waited for a purpose to form, then started toward the shed where the mower was kept. It would come later if it came at all. Sometimes it didn't. He lost patience and hardly ever thought of them again, and then, with a regret that he recognized as mostly polite. Same with a colleague who was killed not long ago on Lake Tahoe when he hit a beer cooler while water skiing. But then, water skiing was such an untragic way to go, and the derelict cooler, a ludicrous touch.
他摇摇晃晃地站起来，酸溜溜地环顾四周，等待某种目标成形，然后朝存放割草机的棚子走去。如果有的话，之后会来的。有时不会。他失去了耐心，几乎再也没想过他们，即使想到了，那种遗憾他也明白大多是出于客套。就像不久前一个同事在太浩湖滑水时撞到啤酒冷却器而身亡。但滑水是一种多么不悲剧的离开方式啊，那个被遗弃的冷却器，真是个荒诞的细节。
No, if it came, it would come from behind and push him into a hole so deep he'd forget what it was like to be out of it. That was what happened with his beautiful niece, Margaret, his sister's only child. She was 28. Joe had warned her. She had diabetes and was drinking heavily. But somehow, he'd failed to expect it himself. He got clobbered a few weeks after her death, laid low.
不，如果它真的会来，它会从背后袭来，把他推进一个深不见底的洞里，让他忘了身处其外是什么感觉。这就是在他美丽的侄女玛格丽特——他姐姐唯一的孩子——身上发生的事。她28岁。乔曾警告过她。她患有糖尿病，且酗酒严重。但不知何故，他自己却没预料到。在她去世几周后，他被打垮了，一蹶不振。
Something like it happened to him after his son was born. One night, holding the baby, he remembered with perfect clarity his own father holding him, looking down at him. His father was smiling. There was that roguish gap between his teeth, the crazy, up-curved eyebrow. It was a look of unguarded benevolence. Joe knew it well. He'd grown up in the light of his father's pleasure in him. And now he figured that by some trick of the mind, he had imposed on a scene too distant for recall.
在他儿子出生后，也发生了类似的事。一天晚上，抱着孩子，他清晰地回忆起自己的父亲抱着他，俯视着他。他父亲在微笑。牙齿间有那个调皮的缝隙，那疯狂向上弯曲的眉毛。那是一种毫无防备的仁慈眼神。乔对此很熟悉。他在父亲对他那份快乐的照耀下长大。现在他想，通过某种思维诡计，他强行拼凑了一个距离太遥远而无法回忆的场景。
And then, a few days later, he was doing some paperwork after the clinic closed and looked up into the dim corridor. And there he was in his parents house again, in the hallway just outside their bedroom. And as he stood there, unable to move, the wheezing, yellow-faced monster who had taken his father's place turned slowly and smiled that kindly smile and lifted his long yellow fingers and tried to speak.
几天后，他在诊所关门后处理文书工作，抬头望向昏暗的走廊。他又回到了父母的房子里，就在卧室门外的走廊上。当他站在那里，动弹不得时，那个取代了他父亲的、气喘吁吁、脸色发黄的怪物慢慢转过身，露出那种慈祥的微笑，举起长长的黄手指，试图说话。
Joe cried out, or thought he did. The room had that shocked, expectant air. But if so, no one had heard him.
乔大喊一声，或者以为他喊了。房间里充满了震惊和期待的气氛。但如果是这样，没听到有人出声。
The lawnmower had a bent blade and shook convulsively as Joe worked his way around the yard. it was folly to use it in this condition, but the pushing felt good and he muscled it on. He spun through a corner and saw his mother in the kitchen window, her face overlaid with leaves reflected from the orange tree. She looked worried. Joe raised a hand and she made a little wave back, the same regretful wave she used to give from the departing car when they left him at scout camp in the summer. The same wave, the same uncertain smile, except she was strong and handsome then. And now, she was old and had to wear a diaper.
割草机的刀片弯了，乔在院子里修剪时它剧烈地抖动。在这种状况下用它简直是愚蠢，但推着它的感觉不错，他费力地推动着。他转过一个弯，看到母亲在厨房窗户边，她的脸覆盖着橙子树折射的叶影。她看起来很担忧。乔挥了挥手，她回了一个小小的挥手，那和他们夏天送他去童子军夏令营时，从离去的车里给他做的那个抱歉的挥手一模一样。同样的挥手，同样的迟疑笑容，只不过那时她是强壮而帅气的。而现在，她老了，必须穿着尿布。
He turned his attention to the rock border where he'd pranged the blade last time. And when he looked up again, she was gone. His hands tingled, his brow dripped, his shirt was soaked through. As he worked, he ceased to think, or to feel himself think. And then it came to him. The real estate agent, Chip Ryan. Little Chip. He hadn't placed him at first because the boy had been so young-- just seven or eight-- when Joe left Dunston.
他把注意力转回上次刀片刮伤的岩石边缘。当他再次抬头时，她不见了。他的手发麻，额头滴着汗，衬衫湿透了。干活时，他停止了思考，或者停止了感觉自己在思考。然后他想到了。房产中介，奇普·瑞安。小奇普。他起初没认出他，因为那男孩当时太小了——乔离开邓斯顿的时候才七八岁。
Chip's older brother had been a friend of Joe's. Chip used to hang around while they played records and talked, but he didn't butt in or act bratty. Joe had been struck by that. What a nice little kid he was, little Chip, sitting there with his pet rabbit, stroking its ears while he looked up at the big boys. Little Chip and Mary Claude.
奇普的哥哥曾是乔的朋友。奇普过去经常在他们放唱片聊天时凑过来，但他不会打扰人或表现得很讨嫌。乔对此印象深刻。多好的小孩子啊，小奇普，坐在那里抚摸着他的宠物兔，抬头看着大男孩们。小奇普和玛丽·克劳德。
The letter didn't say whether Chip was married or single. Either way, he was on the prowl, or they wouldn't be telling that story. And of all the girls in that long, green valley, he had to pick Mary Claude, if it was true. Of course it was true. He bullied the mower through the last couple of turns and cut the engine. A pall of exhaust hung above the yard.
信里没说奇普是已婚还是单身。不管怎样，他当时肯定在猎艳，否则他们不会讲那个故事。在那条漫长而翠绿的山谷里的所有女孩中，他偏偏选中了玛丽·克劳德，如果是真的话。当然是真的。他强行推着割草机完成了最后几圈，关掉了引擎。一层废气悬浮在院子上空。
He heard the music again. Violins. Strauss still. He nodded helplessly along as he toweled himself down with his shirt. He'd heard the piece 100 times. 500 hundred times, Candace dancing naked through their apartment to the grand rise and fall of it, gleaming with sweat, eyes half-closed.
他又听到了音乐。小提琴。还是施特劳斯。他一边用衬衫擦汗，一边无奈地随之点头。这首曲子他听过100遍了。500遍了，坎迪丝在他们公寓里随着那宏大的起伏翩翩起舞，赤身裸体，在汗水中闪烁，双眼半闭。
But when he reached for the name, he felt it slip away. It baffled him that he could not hold on to something he'd known so well. And he stood fixed in his puzzlement as the music swelled to a finish and died. And a dog barked somewhere, and another waltz began.
但当他想去捕捉那个名字时，感觉到它溜走了。他对自己竟无法留住如此熟悉的东西感到困惑。音乐攀升至终点并消逝，他僵在困惑中。某处传来了狗叫声，另一首华尔兹开始了。
Tobias Wolff is the author of several books, including The Night in Question and This Boy's Life . His story "Kiss" first appeared in The New Yorker magazine.
托拜厄斯·沃尔夫是多部书籍的作者，包括《有问题的夜晚》和《这个男孩的生活》。他的故事《吻》首次发表在《纽约客》杂志上。
[MUSIC--"I THINK I NEED A NEW HEART" BY THE MAGNETIC FIELDS]
[音乐——磁场乐队的《我想我需要一颗新心》]
Act Two, How a Bill Becomes A President. Our program today is about crushes, and this story is about a very specialized kind of crush, the political crush. This is a crush that wants only for a candidate to get elected to office. It is a rarely-discussed force in our national life.
第二幕，“法案如何成为——总统”。我们今天的节目主题是暗恋，这个故事关乎一种非常特殊的暗恋，政治暗恋。这是一种只想让候选人当选的暗恋。这是我们国民生活中一种鲜少被讨论的力量。
Julia Rothwax, for example, says she doesn't care if she ever speaks with presidential candidate Bill Bradley, but she wants him to win the White House. Her political feelings for him started starring when she saw him talk about the normally uncrushworthy subject of campaign finance reform. Now she's one of his press secretaries in New York.
例如，朱莉娅·罗斯瓦克斯说，她不在乎是否能和总统候选人比尔·布拉德利谈话，但她希望他能赢得白宫。她对比尔·布拉德利的政治情感始于看到他讨论通常不令人动心的议题——竞选财务改革。现在她是他在纽约的新闻秘书之一。
She's worked for one other presidential campaign, for another Bill-- Bill Clinton in 1992. But after Clinton took office, she says the reality of his presidency did not match her hopes for it. She says "crush" isn't exactly the right word for the kind of political feeling that I'm trying to describe.
她曾为另一场总统竞选工作过，为另一位比尔——1992年的比尔·克林顿。但在克林顿上任后，她说他的总统任期现实与她的期望并不相符。她说“暗恋”这个词并不能准确地描述她试图形容的那种政治情感。
But I do think there's parallels to-- that every now and then, somebody comes along that makes you feel extremely hopeful and excited. And then you go through a process of only thinking about that thing and that person.
但我确实认为它有相似之处——每隔一段时间，就会有人出现，让你感到极其充满希望和兴奋。然后你会经历一个只想到那个东西和那个人的过程。
Yeah.
嗯。
What I think it's closer to is the feeling of falling in love than it is to a feeling of a crash. It doesn't feel like a crush to me. It's sort of a process. You have your first meeting or your first acquaintance with the candidate. And at that first meeting, which for me was that campaign finance reform speech that Bradley gave, you're assessing in the same way you would on a first date. I heard the speech and I was moved by it. And I wanted to hear more, and I wanted to learn more, and I got really interested.
我觉得它更接近陷入爱河的感觉，而不是一种迷恋。对我来说这感觉不像暗恋。这是一种过程。你与候选人有了第一次见面或相识。在那次初见中，对我而言就是布拉德利发表的那场竞选财务改革演讲，你就像第一次约会那样在评估他。我听了那场演讲，深受触动。我想听更多，想学更多，我对那个人产生了浓厚的兴趣。
So this is like the curiosity phase.
所以这就像好奇阶段。
The curiosity phase. Yeah. And also the sort of gathering information. You're like, "Who is this person and are they as good as they seem?" Yeah, so you go through that. And then you commit. Then you sign up. I'm a full-time staffer now. So I actually left my job, and I gave stuff up, and I threw myself into this thing. And then you see where it goes.
好奇阶段。没错。还有某种收集信息的过程。你会想，“这个人是谁，他们真的像看起来那么好吗？”是的，你就是这样经历过来的。然后你承诺了。你签了名。我现在是个全职工作人员了。所以我辞了职，放弃了其他东西，全身心地投入到这件事中。然后你看看它会走向何方。
This kind of political falling in love, is there a difference for you in the Bradley campaign from the way that it felt with Clinton?
这种政治意义上的陷入爱河，对你来说，布拉德利竞选团队的感觉与克林顿竞选时有什么不同吗？
Well, yeah, there's a few differences. With Clinton, if it was a political falling in love, it was my first time out. And the first time you fall in love, you fall hard, and then you usually, I guess, end up feeling disillusioned or disheartened. Or your expectations are too high, and then reality sets in.
嗯，是的，有几点不同。和克林顿一起时，如果那算是一种政治上的陷入爱河，那是我的第一次。第一次坠入爱河，你会陷得很深，然后我想通常你会感到幻灭或沮丧。或者你的期望太高，现实就会到来。
And with Bradley, I'm a little bit older, I'm a little bit wiser. And he doesn't-- well, the truth is, he doesn't work it, I guess is the right term. You felt that there was a feeling on the Clinton campaign that everybody should be sort of starry eyed about him.
而和布拉德利一起，我大了一点，也聪明了一点。而且他并不——好吧，事实是，他并不那样经营，我觉得这个词合适。在克林顿的竞选团队中，你会感觉到每个人都应该对他那种眼中闪着星星的状态。
And Bradley's charming in this different way. There's a jazzier, high-school kind of first falling in love that maybe Clinton was for me. And Bradley feels much more serious and much more mature.
而布拉德利以一种不同的方式展现魅力。也许克林顿对我来说更像是一种爵士乐般的、高中时期的初恋。而布拉德利的感觉要严肃得多，成熟得多。
Well, you know that idea that when you get into a new relationship, that it's a reaction to the relationship before--
嗯，你知道那种想法吗，当你进入一段新关系时，它是对上一段关系的反应——
Yeah.
是的。
--so, like, the opposite person of the one who you just were with?
——所以，就像是你刚处过的那个人完全相反的人？
Right. Pendulum. Pendulum swinging, you're talking about.
对。钟摆。你说的是钟摆效应。
Yeah, is that true for you in this case?
是的，在你这个案例中是真的吗？
Let's think about that. I guess with Bradley, I have liked it that one of his themes is that he's telling you what he really thinks. I think partly, with Clinton, what was hard for everybody is that you kind of got the sense that there were a lot of political considerations behind what he did and what he said. And with Bradley, it feels more pure.
让我们想一想。我想和布拉德利在一起，我喜欢他的一大主题是他讲述的是他真实的想法。我认为部分原因是，对于克林顿，每个人觉得困难的是，你有一种感觉，认为他所做和所说的一切背后都有很多政治考量。而布拉德利，感觉更纯粹。
And I have to say, I feel like both of us are approaching this conversation rather tentatively because you have a real job in politics. And so, to talk about the emotional component behind it, it feels a little like, is this is right to talk about? Though I have to say, if you think about people working in politics, if they don't have a feeling behind the work they're doing, if they aren't idealistic at some level-- if you think about people who aren't, your heart sinks.
我不得不说，我觉得我们俩处理这段谈话的方式相当迟疑，因为你在政治界有一份真正的工作。所以，谈论背后的情感成分，感觉有点像，谈论这个合适吗？尽管我必须说，如果你想到从事政治工作的人，如果他们所做的工作背后没有情感，如果他们在某种程度上不是理想主义者——如果你想到那些人不是这样，你的心会沉下去。
You know what I mean? You want to believe that the people who are working with candidates and working in politics are doing it because they believe in something.
你知道我的意思吗？你想相信那些与候选人合作并在政治界工作的人是因为他们相信某些东西。
I think a lot of my friends who I did the '92 campaign with actually-- everybody wants it to happen again, because it's a positive-- it's a good feeling. You get sucked back in, and it takes over your life. And you start caring maybe a little too much. And you do have to be careful about it, because you have to be working for somebody who's going to be responsible with your time and your affections and your commitment, I guess.
我想我那些一起做过92年竞选的朋友其实——每个人都希望它再次发生，因为它是一种积极的——一种好的感觉。你被卷了回去，它占据了你的生活。你开始关心得有点过头了。你确实必须小心，因为你必须为你所服务的人负责，他们会负责你的时间、你的感情和你的承诺，我想是这样。
And I guess I feel like Bradley, he does do that as a candidate. And if you talk about it as a political falling in love, a relationship, and you're looking as you get older, you look for different things. You're looking for balance, and you don't want quite as much of a Clinton-esque roller coaster, I guess.
我觉得布拉德利作为候选人确实做到了这一点。如果你把它称为政治上的坠入爱河，一段关系，随着年龄增长，你会寻找不同的东西。你在寻找平衡，你不想再要像克林顿那样的过山车了，我想是这样。
One of the things, when you have a real crush, or you're really falling in love with a person in a real setting, is that you want to talk about them all the time. And thinking about this kind of political falling in love, you're in a situation where you get to talk about him all the time.
当你真的暗恋，或者在一个真实的环境中真正爱上一个人时，其中一件事情就是你想一直谈论他们。想到这种政治上的坠入爱河，你处于一种可以一直谈论他的情况下。
Right, I'm a press secretary, so my--
没错，我是新闻秘书，所以我的——
It's perfect.
太完美了。
When I'm actually falling in love with a real person in my real life, I don't go around and gush. But with a candidate, it's something to share, so that's what's nice about the gushing about it, is because you do want to tell people. Because you've discovered something that's great. But they can have it too. That's what's different about political falling in love. Anybody could sign up and sign on and help us win this election.
当我真的在现实生活中爱上一个真正的人时，我不会到处宣扬。但对于一个候选人，这是一种可以分享的事情，所以那种到处宣扬的好处在于，你确实想告诉别人。因为你发现了一些伟大的东西。但他们也可以拥有它。这就是政治上的坠入爱河的不同之处。任何人都可以注册并参与其中，帮助我们赢得这次选举。
Julia Rothwax is a press secretary for the Bill Bradley campaign in New York.
朱莉娅·罗斯瓦克斯是比尔·布拉德利在纽约竞选团队的新闻秘书。
[MUSIC--"WEDDING BELL BLUES" BY FIFTH DIMENSION]
[音乐——第五维度的《婚礼铃声蓝调》]
Act Three, On Seeing the 100% Perfect Girl One Beautiful April Morning. We close our show today with this story, with as pure a depiction of unadulterated crush feeling as possibly can be imagined, from Haruki Murakami. It's read for us by actor Matt Malloy.
第三幕，“四月的一个清晨见到百分之百的完美女孩”。我们节目的结尾今天带来这个故事，以尽可能想象到的、最纯粹的未掺杂暗恋感觉的描写，来自村上春树。由演员马特·马洛伊为我们朗读。
One beautiful April morning, on a narrow side street in Tokyo's fashionable Harujuku neighborhood, I walked past the 100% perfect girl.
在一个美丽的四月清晨，在东京时尚的原宿街区的一条狭窄小巷里，我与百分之百的完美女孩擦肩而过。
Tell you the truth, she's not that good looking. She doesn't stand out in any way. Her clothes are nothing special. The back of her hair is still bent out of shape from sleep. She isn't young either-- must be near 30, not even close to a "girl," properly speaking. But still, I know from 50 yards away she's the 100% perfect girl for me. The moment I see her, there's a rumbling in my chest, and my mouth is as dry as a desert.
说实话，她并不算特别漂亮。她没有任何突出的地方。她的衣服也没什么特别的。她后脑勺的头发因为睡觉还弯曲变形着。她也不年轻了——肯定快30岁了，严格来说连“女孩”都算不上。但即使如此，我从50码外就知道，她就是我百分之百的完美女孩。那一刻，我胸中一阵轰鸣，口干舌燥，犹如荒漠。
Maybe you have your own particular favorite type of girl-- one with slim ankles, say, or big eyes, or graceful fingers. Or you're drawn for no good reason to girls who take their time with every meal. I have my own preferences, of course. Sometimes in a restaurant I'll catch myself staring at a girl at the table next to mine because I like the shape of her nose.
也许你也有自己特别心仪的类型——比如苗条的脚踝，或者大眼睛，或者优雅的手指。又或者你毫无理由地被那些吃饭慢吞吞的女孩吸引。我当然也有自己的偏好。有时在餐厅，我会发现自己盯着隔壁桌的女孩看，因为我喜欢她鼻子的形状。
But no one can insist that his 100% perfect girl correspond to some preconceived notion. As much as I like noses, I can't recall the shape of hers, or even if she had one. All I can remember for sure is that she was no great beauty. It's weird.
但没人能坚持说他百分之百的完美女孩符合某种先入为主的概念。尽管我喜欢鼻子，但我回想不起她的形状，甚至想不起她有没有鼻子。我唯一能确定记得的是，她并非绝世美人。这很奇怪。
She's walking east to west and I west to east. It's a really nice April morning. Wish I could talk to her. Half an hour would be plenty. Just ask her about herself, tell her about myself, and, what I'd really like to do, explain to her the complexities of fate that led to our passing each other on a side street in Harujuku on a beautiful April morning in 1981. This was something sure to be crammed full of warm secrets. It's like an antique clock built when peace filled the world.
她从东向西走，我从西向东走。这是一个非常美好的四月清晨。真希望能和她谈谈。半小时就足够了。就问问她的事，告诉她我的事，而且，我真正想做的是，向她解释导致我们在1981年一个美丽的四月清晨在原宿小巷里擦肩而过的命运复杂性。这肯定是一个充满了温暖秘密的故事。就像一个在世界充满和平时制造的古董钟。
After talking, we'd have lunch somewhere. Maybe see a Woody Allen movie. Stop by a hotel bar for cocktails. With any kind of luck, we might end up in bed.
聊完后，我们会去某处吃午饭。也许看看伍迪·艾伦的电影。去酒店酒吧喝鸡尾酒。运气好的话，我们可能会去床上。
Potentiality knocks on the door of my heart.
潜力敲响了我心脏的大门。
Now the distance between us has narrowed to 15 yards. How can I approach her? What should I say?
现在我们之间的距离缩小到15码了。我该如何接近她？我该说些什么？
"Good morning, miss. Do you think you could spare half an hour for a little conversation?"
“早上好，小姐。你觉得能抽出半小时聊聊吗？”
Ridiculous. I'd sound like an insurance salesman.
太荒谬了。我会听起来像个推销保险的。
"Pardon me, but would you happen to know if there's an all-night cleaner in the neighborhood?"
“打扰一下，请问您知道这附近有没有通宵洗衣店吗？”
No, this is just as ridiculous. I'm not carrying any laundry, for one thing. Who's going to buy a line like that? Maybe the simple truth would do.
不，这也同样荒谬。首先，我没拿任何衣服。谁会买这种账？也许简单直接的真相会有效。
"Good morning. You are the 100% perfect girl for me."
“早上好。你是我的百分之百完美女孩。”
No, she wouldn't believe it. Or even if she did, she might not want to talk to me. Sorry, she could say, I might be the 100% perfect girl for you, but you're not the 100% perfect boy for me. It could happen. And if I found myself in that situation, I'd probably go to pieces. I'd never recover from the shock. I'm 32, and that's what growing older is all about.
不，她不会相信的。即使相信，她可能也不想跟我说话。抱歉，她可能会说，我可能是你的百分之百完美女孩，但你不是我的百分之百完美男孩。这完全可能发生。如果我发现自己陷入那种境地，我可能会崩溃。我永远无法从打击中恢复。我32岁了，这就是成长的代价。
We pass in front of a flower shop. A small, warm air mass touches my skin. The asphalt is damp, and I catch the scent of roses. I can't bring myself to speak to her. She wears a white sweater. and in her right hand she holds a crisp, white envelope lacking only a stamp. So, she's written somebody a letter. Maybe spent the whole night writing, to judge from the sleepy look in her eyes. The envelope could carry every secret she's ever had.
我们经过一家花店。一小团温暖的空气触碰到我的皮肤。沥青路面潮湿，我闻到了玫瑰的香气。我无法强迫自己去和她说话。她穿着一件白色毛衣，右手拿着一个清脆的白色信封，只缺一枚邮票。所以，她给某人写了封信。也许整晚都在写，看她睡眼惺忪的样子。那个信封可能承载着她有过的每一个秘密。
I take a few more strides and turn. She's lost in the crowd.
我再迈出几步，转过身。她已经淹没在人群中了。
Now, of course, I know exactly what I should have said to her. It would've been a long speech, though, far too long for me to have delivered it properly. The ideas I come up with are never very practical. It would have started, once upon a time, and ended, a sad story, don't you think?
现在，当然，我知道我当时应该对她说什么。不过那会是一段很长的独白，太长了，我无法妥善地表达出来。我想出的点子从来都不怎么实际。它本会以“从前”开始，以“一个悲伤的故事，你不觉得吗？”结束。
Once upon a time, there lived a boy and a girl. The boy was 18 and the girl 16. He was not unusually handsome, and she was not especially beautiful. They were just an ordinary lonely boy and an ordinary lonely girl, like all the others. But they believed with their whole hearts that somewhere in the world, there lived the 100% perfect boy and the 100% perfect girl for them. Yes, they believed in a miracle, and that miracle actually happened. One day, they came upon each other on the corner of a street.
从前，住着一个男孩和一个女孩。男孩18岁，女孩16岁。他不算特别英俊，她也不算特别漂亮。他们只是普通的孤独男孩和普通的孤独女孩，和其他人一样。但他们全心全意地相信，在这个世界上的某个地方，住着属于他们的百分之百完美男孩和百分之百完美女孩。是的，他们相信奇迹，而奇迹真的发生了。有一天，他们在街角相遇了。
"This is amazing," he said. "I've been looking for you all my life. You may not believe this, but you are the 100% perfect girl for me."
“这真是太神奇了，”他说。“我找了你一辈子。你可能不信，但你是我的百分之百完美女孩。”
"And you," she said to him, "are the 100% perfect boy for me, exactly as I pictured you in every detail. It's like a dream."
“而你，”她对他说，“是我的百分之百完美男孩，就像我在每一个细节中所描绘的那样。这就像一场梦。”
They sat on a park bench, held hands and told each other their stories hour after hour. They were not lonely anymore. They had found and been found by their 100% perfect other. What a wonderful thing it is to find and be found by your 100% perfect other. It's a miracle, a cosmic miracle.
他们坐在公园的长椅上，手拉着手，一小时又一小时地向对方倾诉自己的故事。他们不再孤独了。他们找到了，也被各自的百分之百完美伴侣找到了。寻找并被你的百分之百完美伴侣找到，是一件多么美妙的事情啊。这是一个奇迹，一个宇宙奇迹。
As they sat and talked, however, a tiny, tiny, sliver of doubt took root in their hearts. Was it really all right for one's dreams to come true so easily?
然而，当他们坐着交谈时，一颗微小的、极其细小的怀疑种子在心中扎了根。梦想如此轻易地实现真的好吗？
And so, when there came a momentary lull in the conversation, the boy said to the girl, "Let's test ourselves just once. If we really are each other's 100% perfect lovers, then sometime, somewhere, we will meet again without fail. And when that happens, we will know the we are the 100% perfect ones. We'll marry then and there. What do you think?"
于是，当谈话出现片刻停顿时，男孩对女孩说，“让我们测试一下自己一次。如果我们真的是彼此百分之百完美的爱人，那么在某时某地，我们一定会再次相遇。当那发生时，我们会知道我们是彼此百分之百完美的那个人。到那时我们就在那里结婚。你觉得呢？”
"Yes," she said. "That is exactly what we should do."
“好，”她说。“这正是我们应该做的。”
And so they parted, she to the east and he to the west. The test they had agreed upon, however, was utterly unnecessary. They should never have undertaken it, because they really and truly were each other's 100% perfect lovers, and it was a miracle that they had ever met. But it was impossible for them to know this, young as they were. The cold, indifferent waves of fate proceeded to toss them unmercifully.
于是他们分手了，她向东，他向西。然而，他们商定的那个测试完全是不必要的。他们本不该进行测试，因为他们确实、真正是彼此百分之百完美的爱人，他们能够相遇简直是个奇迹。但以他们当时年轻的程度，不可能知道这一点。冷酷、冷漠的命运之浪开始无情地抛掷他们。
One winter, both the boy and the girl came down with the season's terrible influenza. And after drifting for weeks between life and death, they lost all memory of their earlier years. When they awoke, their heads were as empty as the young D.H. Lawrence's piggy bank.
一个冬天，男孩和女孩都患上了季节性重感冒。在生死边缘徘徊数周后，他们失去了对早年岁月的全部记忆。当他们醒来时，他们的头脑就像年轻的D·H·劳伦斯的存钱罐一样空空如也。
They were two bright, determined young people, however. And through their unremitting efforts, they were able to acquire once again the knowledge and feeling that qualified them to return as full-fledged members of society. Heaven be praised, they became truly upstanding citizens who knew how to transfer from one subway line to another, who were capable of sending special delivery letters at the post office. Indeed, they even experienced love again, sometimes as much as 75% or even 85% love.
然而，他们是两个聪明、坚定的年轻人。通过不懈的努力，他们能够再次获得使自己作为社会正式成员回归所需的知识和感受。感谢上苍，他们成为了真正正直的公民，知道如何转乘地铁，有能力在邮局寄出特快专递信件。事实上，他们甚至再次体验了爱情，有时是75%甚至85%的爱情。
Time passed with shocking swiftness. Soon, the boy was 32, the girl 30. One beautiful April morning, in search of a cup of coffee to start the day, the boy was walking from west to east, while the girl, intending to send a special delivery letter, was walking from east to west, both along the same narrow street in the Harujuku neighborhood of Tokyo. They passed each other in the very center of the street. The faintest gleam of their lost memories glimmered for the briefest moment in their hearts. Each felt a rumbling in the chest, and they knew.
时间流逝得惊人迅速。很快，男孩32岁，女孩30岁。一个美丽的四月清晨，为了寻找一杯咖啡开始新的一天，男孩从西向东走，而女孩为了寄出一封特快专递，从东向西走，两人都在东京原宿街区同一条狭窄的街道上。他们在街道正中央擦肩而过。他们失落的记忆在心中闪过一丝微光，仅在短暂的一瞬间。每个人都感到胸中一阵轰鸣，他们知道了。
She is the 100% perfect girl for me.
她是我的百分之百完美女孩。
He is the 100% perfect boy for me.
他是我的百分之百完美男孩。
But the glow of their memories was far too weak, and their thoughts no longer had the clarity of 14 years earlier. Without a word, they passed each other, disappearing into the crowd forever. A sad story, don't you think?
但记忆的光芒太微弱了，他们的思维已不再具备14年前那样的清晰度。他们一言不发地擦肩而过，永远消失在人群中。一个悲伤的故事，你不觉得吗？
Yes. That's it. That's what I should've said to her.
是的。就是这样。那才是我应该对她说的。
Haruki Murakami's short story is in his collection of stories, The Elephant Vanishes . Our reader, Matt Malloy, can be seen in the films Cookie's Fortune , In the Company of Men, Election , and so many more.
村上春树的短篇故事收录在他的故事集《象的失踪》中。我们的朗读者马特·马洛伊，可以在《饼干的财富》、《男人在公司》、《选举》以及更多电影中见到。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, and Blue Chevigny. Production help from Todd Bachmann and [? Erik Hoversten. ?]
好了，我们今天的节目由朱莉·斯奈德和我自己制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、苏珊·伯顿和蓝色·切维尼参与。感谢托德·巴赫曼和[？埃里克·霍弗斯滕？]提供的制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. What does it mean that he greets me every day with,
WBEZ管理监督：托里·马拉蒂亚。他每天用这句话迎接我，这到底意味着什么？
Good morning. You are the 100% perfect girl for me.
“早上好。你是我的百分之百完美女孩。”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。